*pop to end all pops*
Good evening, I'm Poppy Harlow and welcome to Pew News,
Youtube's number one news source organization
...
(Windows xp shutdown sound at distance)
*Pew News intro*
BUP! We got breaking news coming in guys. Breaking news! This is breaking news happening right here (where?)
YouTube is putting ($)25 million towards news initiatives. (wut)
...
That's amazing!
*gloriah borgah intro* Oh my gah! Thank you finally, Pew News gets recognized!
Okay, so how many millions are (is) Pew News, getting?
Wait,
say that again.
...
Nothing??
But Pew News is the #1 news source on YouTube...
This doesn- this doesn't make any sense...
Okay, fine.
Who are they giving it to then? Who are they giving the millions to?
Vox... Vox Media?? *dont trust them*
Ooh... ohh...
Oh, Vox! They're-
They're giving it to Vox Media...
Vox Media, they givin' it to- give it to Vox!
Yes! Give it to Vox!!
Yeah... Vox Media that owns The Verge
Vox Media?!? *Poppy Harlow having a seizure no seriously please send emergency aid immediately*
*this "Please Hold" screen brought to you and paid for by Vox Media*
*gross sounds as she becomes herself again*
*this "Please Hold" screen sponsored by The Verge*
Good evening,
*pop of The Vox™*
I'm Poppy Harlow, you're watching Pew News, the most
UUNNDDEERRRAATTEEDD
news source on YouTube.
:D
Basically, what's happening here is that- you- Google is...
"expanding their news initiative."
This will affect how videos are ranked on YouTube.
They will also start adding a little text to inform people to base their own opinion on certain subjects.
YouTube's saying that "YouTube has a responsibility to make authoritive (authoriTATIVE)
sources readily available,
provide context to help people make their own decision, and support
Journalism with technology that allows news to thrive."
YouTube has been criticized a lot by the media (WSJ) - maybe you don't know about this -
for promoting conspiracy videos and fake news videos.
The way YouTube's algorithm works
is that the more you watch, the more you will be (will have) promoted something.
So, if you go down the rabbit hole on certain
"subjects," you can get a lot of information that may or may not be true.
So, this is a move that YouTube is making to combat that.
Why they thought to don- give money to Vox, meanin-
(cmonBruh)
I don't know.
To give my actual opinion about it - I'm not supposed to do it
*pop by Verge Media™*
cuz I'm Poppy Harlow, I'm just brr-
*Pewds has a stroke*
...my opinion.
From a news perspective, it makes sense.
It's a good move for YouTube to make.
I think there will be positive changes in that regard, but I- there's also
changes that I personally feel conflicted about
in the sense of "I don't know whether this will actually be a positive or a negative outcome."
From a community perspective,
this looks really bad for YouTube.
*extreme zoom technology*
Maybe it's the timing?
Susan Wojcicki, CEO of YouTube, tweeted this story out on her- on the...
on the Google Blog
saying "Today, we shared YouTube's ($)25 million investment to support future of news in online video.
To be honest,
there's a lot of gross replies in the comments.
I wish people were more mature. *🤔 hmmm 🤔*
Filtering through all the BS, there are some legitimate claims from a lot of people in the community
saying such things as "one of the last things I was looking for from YouTube was a way to bring in
even more mainstream media outlets who have a habit (and
incentive) to discredit and undermine the creatives who have made your platform the success it is."
I couldn't put it better myself.
Going on other people saying "this is the opposite of what everyone wants, the viewers watch YouTube because it isn't
TV because you don't get slammed with old men trying to tell you what to think.
The second you give MSN (which caused the Adpocalypse-)" uh-
oh, I thought it was PewDiePie...
guess I got it wrong, huh?
"...a platform over your creators(,) you forfeit your integrity."
What is your opinion on this subject matter?
I... I'm not upset or anything.
Uhh,
I'm sure I'm gonna get the call any moment
and, ehh...
Yeah, that's right YouTube, I'm waiting.
I'm waiting. :D
Next news™ (meme review + Gloriah Borger + PPPPPPoppy Harlow)
*pop by VoxTube™*
As you guys probably know, 12 Thai boys got locked in a cage...
sounds like a...
like the start of a comedy st-
Comedy story or like a joke.
No, it's real. Sorry, I didn't mean to joke about it, but they've been freed. Okay, calm down.
They free now.
Look how happy they are now.
Basically, to summarize very quickly,
Twelve- I think they're part of a football team. They got locked in a cage *cave* because of rainwater
trapping them inside. They were there for literally weeks
and a lot of people-
they were in there for weeks because it was really complicated to get them out because the tunnel is very long
and it's very narrow. They can't swim the distance themselves.
So how are we going to transport these kids into safety? (to safety)
𝔸𝕓𝕤𝕠𝕝𝕦𝕥𝕖 𝕊𝕦𝕡𝕖𝕣𝕙𝕖𝕣𝕠 𝕃𝕖𝕘𝕖𝕟𝕕 "𝔼𝕝𝕠𝕟 𝕄𝕦𝕤𝕜," instead of sitting on his $millions$ (If I were him, I'd want to give Pew News the $25 mil)
said "Hey, I'm gonna try and help out here!
I'm gonna use my money and influence to try and save these kids!"
Absolute 𝕄𝔸𝔻 𝕃𝔸𝔻
He brought the top engineers in the world that works on (for) SpaceX,
paused them from their work that they're doing,
to help out these kids. (what a fantastic person, honestly)
*insert Elon Musk being a godsend to this godforsaken Earth*
*he's the hero we need*
*but not the one we deserve*
*if only there were more people like him...*
People saying "Uhh, no, this won't work, it won't get through the narrow passage..."
𝕄𝔸𝔻𝕄𝔸ℕ Elon showing:
nuh-uh, this will totally work.
A lot of people had, for some reason, a lot of cr- things to say about this:
"This wasn't 'selfless' (uh) - selfless would have been to quietly work on it and then not say anything about it. (???? homie what)
His Tweets about this submarine were more about what he could do and less about actually helping." (but he's at least making an ATTEMPT, why is that such a bad thing?? keyboard warriors dude... smh)
Other people saying "Why is Elon Musk trying to hijack the spotlight from this amazing Thai rescue team through it-
his unsolicited insertion into the mission?" (you mean him actually making an effort to help the cause as opposed to sitting on a chair typing crap like this on Twitter? wow what a horrible person!)
"""Unsolicited."""
How DARE he try and help!!
"If he really wanted to help, he could have easily been more subtle-"
Oh, yOu'rE sO oVer tHe toP, ELON, "...just like countless other
international cave experts and divers.
Hashtag™ (a subsidiary of Twitter)
Tasteless."
"I started engineering-"
Elon hasn't, by the way...
"So I kNoW a LoT mOrE aBoUt ThIs ThAn U Bla-bla-bla-"
Now, as it turns out they got the kids out of the cave without this submarine and help from Elon
and the news headline read this: "Elon Musk offer 'not practical' for cave mission, Thai rescue chief says."
But, contrary to what this title says is that this-
this wasn't a statement from the Thai rescue (chief/team);
Elon had been talking with the actual rescue chief
and, up until the very last minute,
they said "We're worried about the smallest lad. Please keep working on the capsule details."
They also delivered it to Thailand saying "[the] mini-sub [is] arriving in about 17 hours. Hopefully useful.
If not, perhaps it will be in [a] future situation.
I can only imagine...
...how it would feel like trying to do something good -
trying to do something positive, spending your own time and effort and money into something -
then to just get ridiculed by headlines saying "Oh, he wasn't necessary,"
or "Oh, how could he just chime in like this? No one asked for your help, Elon."
Meanwhile, everyone else has sat on their butts...
He's a guy that saw that he could help and he took the chance.
This led to a lot of charged emotions,
that's why I'm bringing this co- super long context.
One person saying "I wonder how often Elon would rather be a physics engineer
or a lead technical designer instead of carrying the label 'billionaire,'
because 'billionaire' in- now, has a negative
uh- connotation to it.
It's a negative thing to be called a 'billionaire' even though everyone wants to be rich,
and this is what one of the people said on Twitter:
"You are literally a billionaire.
*Literally*.
It's not ironic in any way;
you weren't called a 'billionaire' until you were a billionaire.
If you think it's a negative label, maybe it's because it means you're hoarding money and resources from the rest of the world."
🤔🤔🤔🤔🤔🤔🤔🤔🤔🤔🤔
What???
Elon Musk creating...
electric cars,
amazing cool space projects,
and literally flamethrowers, guys-
which I haven't gotten yet, Elon, what the frick?
Apparently he's hoarding money and resources.
Elon responded to this tweet saying "No, I created jobs for 50,000 people directly through part suppliers and supporting professions,
250(k) indirectly, thus supporting half-a-million families.
What have you done?" (fricking burned, dude)
Basically, just responding to a hateful tweet,
informing them "No, this is the truth."
Then, for some reason, YouTuber and entrepreneur, Hank Green, chimed in as well calling Elon out directly saying:
"Hi, I'd like to remind everyone at my companies that I didn't create your jobs,
we all do that together by making good things. (what?)
I do not feed your children, you do.
I'm so- I'm so, so lucky to share your talent n' skill and I have-
personally benefit in many ways from your hard work."
"You can agree with Elon that he's a job creator and also agree that he shouldn't have clapped back to a stranger in anger when (he is) a billionaire with millions of very passionate followers."
So, if you're a billionaire, you're not allowed to defend yourself towards (from) hate comments.
I know Hank means well, but I don't understand why he chose to defend a hate comment, especially coming from someone who's a Youtuber himself.
I hate this sentiment that- "if you have a lot of followers, you're not allowed to-
respond to someone being ignorant or hateful."
Sure, maybe you're supposed to be better than that.
But Hank, you lit- did literally the same thing to Elon and you tagged him in it...
How is that any different?
If you get a dumb comment from someone calling you out directly,
to respond - to inform them why they're being wrong - it's at least, right, yea- the least thing you could possibly do. (You should, at the very least, be able to respond.)
I don't know, this whole situation just annoyed me in general
because you have someone who's a billionaire, who breaks free from the-
regular pattern of a billionaire, just being greedy sitting on all his money, *insert a billion and million meme*
instead, spending it, creating more jobs,
trying to do positive things,
But somehow, we dismiss it as something bad because "Oh, he responded to that one comment in a rude way."
First of all, what do you think of this situation?
(I know how I certainly feel and it's not optimistic...)
I'm always interested in hearing your comments.
Now, speaking of Twitter drama...
*drama pop*
This one is a bit complicated as wel,
but that's why I'm here to fill you in, to...
*pop of filling you guys in*
pop you guys up on the news.
Another victim...
Writer for a Guild Wars 2 got fired latel- a few days ago now
I can't see why she got fired. But apparently it was because some tweets and I'm blocked
So what am I gonna do? Huh? I never interacted with this person before in my life. I don't even know who she is, but
With some carefully crafted cyber engineering I have managed to figure out
How to get past this block? Oh, there we go
I am in guys *damn poopy got some skills*
I'm in. Maybe you heard about this story before it took me a long time to fully understand what is happening here
Why does she get fired? on July 3rd
she tweeted out a very long Twitter thread talking about MMOs talking about what makes a character
Compelling in MMOs and her opinion on the subject matter. absolute disgusting man DeroirGaming
I can't believe he said this guys. This is pretty shocking stuff
So please if you don't have a parental guardian next to you I encourage you to get one right now, /thats good cuz were just 9 yrs old/ yay.
Maybe someone you can hold hands with because this is what he said guys. I can't I honestly can't believe it really
really Interesting thread to read. Oh
How could he however no I here he comes here he comes here come allow me to disagree *slightly*
*2nd Seizure in 11 min* I cant! AH this is too much
How could he say this how could he say this?
Basically, he gives his own opinion on what she said in the most respectful manner
I have ever seen anyone criticize someone or at least give feedback and comment on someone now
This is just not some random guy
Deroir does Guild Wars gaming's like someone I don't know if it's true
But apparently he is even an NPC in the game named after him. He investigates lore in the game
So arguably he's someone that you probably want some feedback from because he probably knows a thing or two
Jessica Price didn't see this way however and decided this was completely a gender issue *now that's wut dis is all about
Because she's a female game dev and people just want to explain how you do your job. This was not just feedback
This was someone telling you no, no, no. No, this is ha ha
this is how you do your job. Deroir even saying that this was never about
Gender it never was never will I will retract my comment because obviously I'm in the wrong forum for this kind of talk
she then proceeded to call him a
random asshat, and that anyone else that will tweet her like this will get instant blocked Oh
Actually, you don't even have to tweet her for to get blocked how insecure in your own abilities
Do you have to be to lash out this far to someone just making a suggestion to you giving you some feedback?
For anyone working in the business should be thankful to getting this kind of feedback
She then preceding that there's a lot of hurt man feels today cuz only men got annoyed by this thing
There was no females at all because this was clearly all about gender
Implying that anyone who disagreed with her is just a man.
This led to her being fired
confirmed by Mike O'Brien on ArenaNet and people were happy.
I'm Poppy Harlow. I'm not supposed to give my opinion
*POWP*
I personally find that anyone that blocks someone on Twitter that you never even interact with don't care about reaching conclusions
Obviously they don't care about solving problems
They just care about playing a victim and it's so transparent here with her tweets
This had nothing to do about her being a woman but clearly in this case
inarguably
It had nothing to do with it. This is also the kind of person that tweets out
I'm glad he's no longer around about totalbiscuit who recently died
from cancer
A YouTube game critic it was respected by a lot of people. That's what she had to say about it
So it's kind of hard to sympathize with her, but I'm gonna try my best
She wouldn't have gotten fired
If she was a guy there's plenty of guys who are game developers who act this sort of snarky
rudest way for example a lot of people bringing up Hideki Kamiya
Who created Devil May Cry among other games who's notorious for
Blocking people in a very similar fashion and kind of lashing out against people just for tweeting at him. Why doesn't he get fired?
Well, he's a let first of all he's a legendary game creator. She's a
writer, she for *wut*our year second of all I never seen this person. For example
Since we're bringing him in to talk down on anyone trying to give him any any feedback in this manner making an issue in social
Politics and whatnot. The second argument I've seen is that people are saying this is her private Twitter?
So what she says there shouldn't matter and she herself sort of went through with this sentiment saying dude
we've still got people outraged that I'm not interested in talking to them on my personal Twitter on federal holiday and
Peter fries who got fired as well. He's the other guy that got
These are private social media accounts
Imagine you're an astronomer and you start sharing some things you've learned in the last few months since you began a research project
Observing Saturn only to have observation techniques explained to you by a layman
so what. There's no reason to lash out in this way and
Twitter is not a private
Conversation group it's not your private teamspeak. It's not your private chat on Skype. It's public
That's the point of Twitter
If you tweet out your opinion publicly people have the right to give their opinion publicly as well
That's not some way of attacking anyone
That's just having a normal conversation
in public which Twitter is, if you want to give your opinion on something and not get
Criticized then don't share it publicly
It's that simple
/p0p/My name is poppy Harlow
You've been filled in
Thank you guys for watching and leaving a like and hitting that subscribe button to keep up with all my videos
I upload videos every single day.  Thank you guys so much for the support. I got some Merch coming out . *laughs for no reason*
Buy that, that would be great. I got nothing right now, but it will come. Thank you guys and goodbye. *stares at computer for nothing* *seeing if he has reached the 10 min mark*
The outro
music slowly fades away
Hey guys, just wanted to tell you that there isn't just 1 caption guy. This meme is really annoying, so it'd be great if you could just stop. Thank you for your understanding r/PewdiepieSubmissions